hi I'm very excited to be returning his
Johnny silverhead in the upcoming
expansion for cyberpunk 2077.
Phantom Liberty
this new adventure reunites Johnny and V
on a dangerous spy mission and
introduces Idris Elba as secret agent
Solomon Reed
it's really amazing to share the screen
with you Idris it's cool to be a part of
this game with you man
um as a player
you'll get to visit Dogtown an
unexplored part of night City and rescue
the president of the new United States
of America
expect a massive expansion twists
secrets and plenty of stuff to do
I know the team at CD projekt Red just
keeps raising the bar when it comes to
telling cinematic stories and video
games and I really can't wait for you to
play it on Xbox series X and S
but enough talking I'm guessing you want
to see for yourself and so it is my
honor and pleasure to give you
and introduce the official trailer for
Phantom Liberty
there's got to be a way out of this
I'm dying
[Music]
the
my name is songworth I'm an nus
intelligence analyst I know about the
bomb ticking in your head
and I can save your life
what's the catch
we need you to get to Dogtown
attention all dog Town residents
president managed to crash her space
Force One into our humble District
man's got a thousand and one reasons to
want Myers as a hostage sleeper agents
time to wake them up
so nusa is tossing us back into The Fray
huh station we're in the Wolves then now
get Myers out of there time to eat back
her safety is the top priority
catch us out here we're dead wait hear
that
[Music]
ratted us out
you know the treason ain't never black
and white it's a charade V wherever she
goes people get hurt bodies dropped just
one word Songbird promised me
care
[Music]
situation has changed you need to know
if you're with me illusion of Freedom
draws in the desperate take your truth
be come on got iron in your head gotta
put it to someone's head pull the
trigger
do anything and do it soon I'll die